this right here is the LA dog also known
as the street meat it's not the bacon or
the dog that makes this hot dog it's the
grilled onions the grilled jalapenos a
baking sheet and some sterno flames it's
disgusting it's not to code but this is
in delicious in LA when it's 2 a.m. and
you need to eat the tastiest thing in
the fastest way possible after you've
been dancing all night long usually when
you put one of these in your mouth
you're really sweaty out-of-breath oh my
god just mayo on a hot dog the mayo is
no it's not it barely got any dog you're
so distracted by the toppings there's so
many different things here just like Los
Angeles the melting pot of the world a
Chicago dog has poppy seed bun bagel
Vienna sausage she got your green relish
hot peppers tomato onion mustard no
ketchup ketchup is a [ __ ] condiment
in my opinion why does this look like
that
that's relish its meal kind of feel like
I should have like one of those glow
stick tongue things
who goes to a hot dog place and says let
me get a whole slab of pickle because
pickles are good you could wrap the
hotdog itself in this pickle oh yeah
that's a good dog as the fat person here
I will say that I feel skinny in Chicago
and this might be one of the reasons I
never say anything bad about Chicago
people because it's so it's so sweet
they think they have a city if you ever
ask for ketchup on a hotdog in Chicago
you will not get served a hotdog
which is it's ketchup before it's like
apt
guys this is a New York hotdog the dirty
water dog it's got mustard it's got some
sweet onions whatever you want to do to
your dog you do um onions go on the dog
listen I believe a gatekeeper to what
goes in my mouth
it's about capitalism and like democra
this is all minimalism it looks like New
York how beat up it is what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger this looks like
something you'd find at the bottom of
your purse at the end of the night and
if you were drunk enough you wouldn't
eat it
New York doesn't need to sound appealing
to LA LA dog for the win la da la da la
is the clear winner of Chicago Chicago
dog who doesn't like me on things I want
to apologize to my family to my uncle's
to my grandmother's um this la dog uh it
beats the Chicago dog funny yo lay one
New York dog all the way at La dock New
York hotdog what is it
hey anyway it's not so much all you need
that is all your best part about New
York we don't even talk about you other
cities we don't even talk about I don't
even know where you guys are frog it
doesn't matter to me are you kidding me
hurry so but there is no ketchup allowed
I'm not gonna let you use this